ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาตี 5 สวยครับน้องเรียม
สวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคนด้วยครับอ่ะสวัสดี
ครับสวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนโอเควัน
นี้เราก็มาเจอกันอีกแล้วกลับมาเจอกับพี่
อาร์ตี้แล้วตอนน้องเรียมมาเรียนภาษาไทย
กันว้าววันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษาไทยกับด้วย
กันนะครับวันนี้ขอให้เราจะเรียนก่อนที่
เราจะเรียนวันนี้วันอะไรครับวันนี้อ้าอัน
นี้วันพฤหัสค่ะวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีนะอ้าวัน
พฤหัส
นะปากกาของพี่อาร์ตี้อยู่หนใดโอเคอยู่
แล้วมาแล้ววันนี้วันพฤหัสบดีวันพฤหัสบดี
ที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันนี้วันพฤหัสที่
35 วันนี้วันที่ 30 วันพฤหัสที่ 30
เดือนเดือน
คุณยายอ้นยายอ้นโอเคปีคริสตศักราช
2,000  21 ใช่ไหมครับน้าให้แล้วแล้วอีก
อี
พุทธศาสตร์
2564 แล้วนะครับว้าววันพฤหัสที่ 30
กันยายน
2541 พ.ต.ท.
2564 โอเคครับวันคิดพร้อมหรือยังค่ะครับ
ผมตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วหรอ
ตอนนี้เที่ยงที่ที่บ้านพี่เนี่ย 8 โมง
เช้าครับเออ
8:00 น 8:00 น 20 น
าไปหาดโม
แอดโมงอีกนะที่โอเคพี่พี่ขอโทษเก็บแอน
โ*** 10 นาทีนะไม่ใช่ยี่สิบโอเคอ่า
08:10 นตอนเช้าอ่ะวันนี้พร้อมแล้ว
ที่บ้านเลียม
08:10 นเหมือนกันเวลาเหมือนกันใช่เพราะ
ว่าวันนี้เราอยู่ด้วยกันเราอยู่ที่
เชียงใหม่ด้วยกันนะจำได้ไหมเราไป
เชียงใหม่กันโอเค
เดี๋ยวอ่ะตอนนี้ยังเช้าอยู่เราอยู่ที่
เชียงใหม่ตอนเช้าเนี่ยเราจะไปเที่ยวไหน
กันบ้างครับวันนี้หน้าที่แรกที่แรกที่พี่
อาร์ตี้จะพาน้องเรียมจะพานักเรียนทุกคนไป
เที่ยวกันก็คือภูเขากันอ่ะไปเที่ยวบนภู
เขากันนี่ภูเขาวันนี้ครับพี่เพียงตีจะผ่า
น้องเรียมแล้วก็นักเรียนทุกๆคนไปเที่ยว
กันในวันนี้นะครับบนภูเขาสูงโอ้โหสูงหน้า
บนภูเขาส่งหน้ามีวิววิวสวยนี่เป็นวิวมอง
เห็นวิวของฟ้ามองเห็นผู้เขาไกลๆมองเห็น
ปลายไกลๆๆใช่อ่ะเป็นวิวก็เรียกว่าวิวๆอ้า
เป็นวิวทั้งหมดเลยใช่ครับจะได้เห็นวิวสวย
ๆแบบนี้ใช่ครับหน้าแต่แต่ว่าก่อนที่เราจะ
ได้เห็นวิวแบบนี้เราต้องเดินเข้าไป
เดินเข้าไปในป่านะจะได้ไปเห็นวิวแบบนี้
วิวสวยๆแบบนี้ใช่อาหารนี่อาจจะเข้าไปใน
ป่าใกล้ครับเดินเข้าไปในป่าเดินเข้าไปใน
ป่าแล้วก็ขึ้นมาขึ้นไปบนภูเขาภูเขาใช่
เดินขึ้นไปหน้าเราก็ที่นี่เวลาที่เราเข้า
ไปในป่าเนี่ยอ่ะมีอายในประเทศไทยเนี่ยถ้า
มีป่ายในป่าจะมียุง 5 วิธียุงอยู่ในป่า
ด้วยน้องเรียนรู้จักยุงมั้ยรู้จักที่ยุง 5
ตาแบบนี้ที่ประเทศไทยมีอยู่เยอะมากเลย
เยอะหาทรายที่บ้านนักเรียนที่บ้านนัก
เรียนมียุงไหมครับ 555 ขี่คอมเม้นท์บอก
เฮียที่หน่อยว่าที่บ้านนักเรียนมียุงไหม
อ่ะแต่บ้านพี่อาร์ตี้มีมี่ที่ยุงมีอยู่
บ้านด้วยอันเดียวก็มีอยู่ก็โอเคอะเดี๋ยว
วันนี้เราไปเดินป่าเนี่ยเราก็ต้องเจอยุง
หน้าน้องเรียมมีอะไรมาป้องกันยุงไหมป้อง
กันยุงค่ะถ้ามีอะไรครับว่าอ้าวอ๋อใจแล้ว
อันนี้เราไว้ทาใช่ไหมถ้า
We  Are แล้วก็กันยุงใช่เปิดแล้วก็บีบบี
บอกมาว้าวแล้วก็
ค่าอ๋อถ้าไปตรงที่ที่แขนที่ขาตรงที่ไม่
ให้อยู่อาจหน้าเพราะว่ายุงยุงไม่ชอบยุ่ง
ไม่ชอบโลชั่นโอ้ยุงกลัวกลัวโลชั่นนะเท่ๆ
โอเคอ่ะแล้วก็ระหว่างทางระหว่างทางที่เรา
จะไปบนยอดดอยและเราเดินเข้าไปในป่าใช่ไหม
เราก็จะไปเจอกับนี้ครับ
ว้าวสวยงามเลยๆครับช่วงนี้เป็นจุดชมวิว
อ้าอยู่ที่หน้าผาหน้าหน้าผ่านตรงนี้ 5
จุดชมวิวเราสามารถไปนั่งไปยืนแล้วก็ถ่าย
รูปถ่ายรูปวิวสวยๆได้ไม่ใช่ครับจุดจุดก็
เป็นแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะพี่อาร์ตี้อ้าจุดชาย
ครับเป็นจุดเป็นสถานที่ที่อ่ะเป็นตำแหน่ง
ตำแหน่งที่เราไปยืนอยู่อ่ะไปยืนถ่ายรูปไป
ยืนดูยืนชมวิว 5 ชมวิวสวยๆว้าวๆไอ้หลุด
ได้พูดได้ๆๆครับ 5 เป็นจุดแล้วก็วิวชมวิว
วายสายครับหน้าว้าวเดี๋ยวเห็นอะไรนิวส์
นี่บ้างครับ
เลี้ยงเห็นหมอก 5 นี้เป็นมอสีขาวอ้ามี
หมอกสีขาวๆตอนเช้าใช่ไหมหน้าตอนเช้ามี
อากาศเย็นอากาศหนาวตอนเช้ามีหมอบ 5 มี
มอก.เยอะเลยอ้าอย่าลืมเตรียมเสื้อแขนยาว
เสื้อแขนยาวไปด้วยเนื้อหาคราวที่แล้วเรา
เอาเสื้อแขนยาวมาด้วยใช่ไหมอ่ะโอเคอ่า
เห็นพระอาทิตย์นี่ครับว้าวนี่นี่คือพระ
อาทิตย์อยู่ใกล้ๆตรงไก่มากว้าวหาอาทิตย์
สวยเลยพระอาทิตย์ส่องแสงออกมาเป็นสี
สี
คลองอาพาณิชย์ส่องแต่เข้ามาเป็นสีทองมี
โอเคอ่าเมื่อเราอยู่ที่ตื่นชมวิวเหนื่อย
แล้วพักดูพระอาทิตย์ดูหมอกอ่าเสร็จแล้ว
เราก็ไปกันต่อครับน้าวันนี้เพลียซึ่ง 5
อ่าเดี๋ยวเราจะพานักเรียนพาน้องเรียมไป
อีกที่หนึ่งไปกางเต็นท์กันนะถ้าเราไป
เที่ยวที่เชียงใหม่เนี่ยเราจะต้องไปนอน
เต็นท์ไปกางเต็นท์แบบนี้ครับอ้านี่คือ
เต็นท์หน้าเรานอนกันและหนาๆคืนนี้เราจะ
นอนที่เต็นท์ในมีอ่านอนๆนอนให้เป็นใช่
ครับคือนี้เราไม่นอนบ้านไม่นอนที่บ้านนะ
เรานอนที่เต็นท์ใช่นอนเต้นบนภูเขาเลยนอน
อยู่บนภูเขาด้วยอ้านี้ครับด้านล่างก็จะ
เป็นผู้เขาๆเต้นวันนี้อ้าถูกต้องครับอ่า
ไปกางเต็นท์อยู่บนภูเขาเลยใต้ครับอ้าแล้ว
ตอนเช้าเราตื่นขึ้นมาเราก็จะเห็นหมอกเยอะ
แยะเลยมีแบบนี้ดอกช้าๆๆๆมีหมอกเยอะแยะเลย
บนภูเขา
ว่าอ่า
แต่เราต้องเดินขึ้นไปนะเดินให้ไม่
เดินผ่านด้วย
เดินขึ้นไปๆครับๆเดินขึ้นใครขาวใช่ครับ
ต่อไปตางเก็บ
ทราย
แต่เรามียาโลชั่นทากันยุงอายุงก็ Mega
โอเค
โอ้โห
นอกจากมีโลชั่นกันยุงแล้ว
น้องเรียนมีอะไรมาอีกครับนี่คืออะไรครับ
มีไม้ตียุงอ๋อหมายปียุงโอเคอ่าโอ้โห้ไม้
ตียุงอันนี้มันฆ่าอยู่นะครับทำให้อยู่ตา
ตายตายเลยต่างให้เลย
ยุงกลัวยุงบินมาแล้วเราก็สีชุบอา
หมออ๋อว่าว่า
ยุงกลัวน้องเรียมมากเลยเนี่ย
โอเคเดี๋ยวคืนนี้เรานอนเต็นท์กันเสร็จ
แล้วนี้นะครับเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้ตื่นขึ้นมา
หลังจะไปเที่ยวกันต่อไปเที่ยวกันต่อที่
เชียงใหม่มีที่เที่ยวเยอะมีภูเขาอะเราไป
ภูเขามาแล้วเดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้อ่ะพรุ่งนี้เรา
จะไปเที่ยวน้ำตกกันนะอ่านี่น้ำตกนะมีน้ำ
นี่เป็นน้ำนะครับน้ำน้ำตกลงงานตกๆตกลงมา
จากผู้เขาผู้เขาสูงนะแล้วก็มีน้ำไหลลงมา
เรียกว่า
น้ำออกน้ำๆๆครับอ่ะที่น้ำตกก็จะมีน้ำไหล
นอนเนี่ยแล้วก็เราก็
ตกเหมือนปากกาเลยค่ะได้อ่านออกอ่ะอ๋อๆนี่
ประกาศออกชายเขาอ่าอาอาประกาศอกแต่นี่
เป็นน้ำตกบกพี่เทพวาวล์น้ำตกสวยงามมากเลย
นะคะก็เวลาที่มีน้ำตกแวะที่มีน้ำตกลงมา
แล้วก็มีพระอาทิตย์
นะครับอ้าถ้ามีพระอาทิตย์อยู่ตรงนี้อ่ะ
สมมุติมีพระอาทิตย์อยู่ตรงนี้
พระอาทิตย์ก็ส่องแสงลงมาที่น้ำตกส่องแสง
ลงมาที่น้ำตกแบบนี้จะทำให้เกิดอ้าเดี๋ยว
ทำให้เกิดนี่อันนี้เป็นน้ำตกใช่ไหมครับ
แล้วก็มีพระอาทิตย์ส่องแสงมาตรงนี้จะเกิด
นี่ครับ
รุ้งอ้า
รุ้งได้มีรุ้ง
รุ้งกินน้ำหน้ารุ้งก็จะมากินถามต้องหนี
ฮ่าๆคนไทยเรียกว่ารู้น้ำๆรู้มากิจน้ำ
เพราะว่ามีน้ำอยู่ที่นี่เยอะซีรีย์ 5
หน้า
ว้าวแล้วเราก็ไปดูตกกันนะครับ
k5 นี้เขากำลังพายเรืออยู่ในน้องเรียม
เห็นเรือมีเรืออยู่ตรงนี้เขาพายเรืออยู่
ในลำธารครับลำธารก็เวลาที่มีน้ำตกลงมา
แล้วก็น้ำตกลงมาเสร็จแล้วมันก็จะไหลไปตาม
ทางนี้
อันนี้มันจะว่าทานๆ
น่ารำธานีแบบนี้ๆครับเป็นลำธารนะครับน้ำ
ก็จะไหลไปไหลไปเรื่อยๆอยู่ในป่านะครับไหล
ไปในปากเป็นลำธารเค
หือว้าวต้องทานก็เย็นนะคะได้ครับน้ำใน
ลำธารก็เย็นแล้วสามารถลงไปลงไปเล่นน้ำได้
ลงไปว่ายน้ำแนะนำทานได้ได้ครับหน้าให้
รำคาญนอกจากน้ำเย็นแล้วในลำธารมีปลาด้วย
ลา 5 มีปลาอยู่ในเราอ่านด้วยใช่ครับ
อ่ามาเยอะไหมคะมามีปลาเยอะครับมีปลาเยอะ
ด้วยๆมากๆแล้วก็บางคนก็จะมีคนเป็นตกปลา
ด้วยอ้ามีคนไปตกปลานี่ตกปลาแล้วก็มี
อกปากขึ้นมาช้าใช่น้องเตรียมเคยตกปลาไหม
ครับ
เคยค่ะ
ปลาดีก็เคยตกปลาในเขา
ตกปลาแล้วก็เอาปลามากินได้น้าใช่ครับ
โอเคแล้วก็อ่านี่เราไปเที่ยวลำธารกันแล้ว
เดี๋ยวหลังจากที่อีกไปที่ไหนกันต่อคะนะฮะ
เดี๋ยวเราจะไปกันต่อค่ะวันนี้เรามา
เชียงใหม่เราต้องไปเที่ยวหลายๆที่ที่น่า
ให้หาให้ครบเลยนะครับเดี๋ยวพี่จะพาไปอีก
ที่หนึ่งอีกที่นี่ก็มีน้ำเหมือนกันนะมี
น้ำเหมือนกันที่นี่พี่จะพาไปที่
น้ำพุ 5 เมื่อกี้ๆเมื่อกี้น้ำตกและน้ำจะ
ตกลงมาจากที่สูงใช่มั้ยฮะอ่าอันนี้น้ำพุ
น้ำพุจะพุ่งขึ้นไปจากพื้นดินพุ่งขึ้นไปหา
ๆนี่น้ำพุ่งขึ้นไปใช่ครับมีพุ่งขึ้นไปจาก
พื้นดินเป็นน้ำพุน้ำพุอันนี้เป็นน้ำพุ
ร้อนนะร้อนร้อนร้อนชายน้ำพุร้อนน้ำพุร้อน
มากพุ่งขึ้นมาจากพื้นดินอาทิตย์เชียงใหม่
มีน้ำพุร้อนด้วยอ่าโอเคเราเอามือต่อกลับ
ได้ไหมคะเอามือทำไม่ได้ครับมือจับไม่ได้
เพราะว่ามันร้อนมันร้อนจะไม่ได้เลยจับได้
ร้อนมากชายครับหน้าเวลาที่น้ำพุพุ่งขึ้น
มาจากพื้นดินมันก็จะไหลมาไหลมาตามลำธาร
นี้อีกพุ
[เพลง]
จะเอาไข่ไปทำอะไรน้องปุ๊เขาก็เอาไผ่
ไข่ไปซ่อมมาใส่ลงไปในนั้นคุใส่ลงไปในน้ำ
ร้อนใช่ไหมฟ้อนน้ำมันร้อนเอาไข่ใส่ลงไป
ว้าวอ้านี้ครับเขาก็จะมีไข่ให้อ่ะให้เรา
เอาไปต้มไหนน้ำพุร้อนใช่เราก็เอาไข่มา
แขวนไว้ตรงนี้อ่า
ไข่ก็จะแช่อยู่ในน้ำมีแบบนี้มีใครก็จะ
ร้อน
ร้อนเสร็จแล้วไข่ก็จะสุกอ่ะคอกไปสุขใคร
สุขแล้วก็เอาไปทำอะไรครับไข่ที่สุกแล้ว
อ้ากินๆน่าๆๆเราก็จะได้ไข่ต้มนะครับอ่ะ
ได้ไข่ต้มจากน้ำพุร้อนว้าวหา
ๆแล้วก็ฮะเดี๋ยวเราไปน้ำพุร้อนแล้ว
เต็มที่ต่อข้ามีอีกที่หนึ่งที่น่าสนใจที่
พี่อาร์ตี้จะพาและน้องเรียมไปกับนักเรียน
ทุกคนนั้นเดี๋ยวเราเดินต่อวันนี้เดินเยอะ
เดินหน้าเดินไปแล้วไปที่นี่ครับ
ไอที่เอ่อ
วัดทำไปเที่ยววัดกันบ้างไหมครับอ่าเที่ยว
วัดได้ครับไปเที่ยววัดพระธาตุดอยสุเทพ
หน้าเคยได้ยินชื่อไหมอ่านักเรียนเคยได้
ยินชื่อวัดพระธาตุดอยสุเทพนะครับน้าวัด
พระธาตุดอยสะเก็ดอยู่ที่เชียงใหม่นะครับ
นี่เดี๋ยวพี่จะพาขึ้นไปแอปแต่ที่ทางขึ้น
วัดพระธาตุดอยสุเทพอยู่บนภูเขานะอยู่บนภู
เขาอีกแล้วอ่ะอยู่คนผู้นั้น
ถ้าเราจะขึ้นไปบนภูเขาเนี่ยที่มีวัดอยู่
เนี่ยเราจะต้องนี่ครับที
หลังจะต้องเกินขึ้นไปบนภูเขา
[เพลง]
r&d เดินขึ้นบันไดไป
อันนี้เราไม่ต้องเดินในป่านะไม่ต้องเดิน
ป่าแล้วไม่มีป่าอันนี้เป็นบันได
ชายนี่เดินขึ้นบันไดไป
ขึ้นบันไดเดินขึ้นไปต่อที่วัดพระธาตุดอย
สุเทพมีบันไดสูง
300 ท่าน
อาร์มร้องให้ท่านๆเดินขึ้นไป 300 ขั้นเลย
ใช่
300 ท่านไหวไหม
ว่าไอ้ไม้
เรียมคิดว่า
เดินไหวเดินไหวโอเคถ้าเดินไหวก็เดี๋ยวเรา
เดินขึ้นไปบน
วัดพระธาตุดอยสุเทพมีแต่ถ้านักเรียนแล้ว
เรียนคนไหนเดินไม่ไหวก็เดินมาหิวอายเด็ก
จะไม่ไหวเดี๋ยวมีที่พระธาตุดอยสุเทพ ML
ด้วยไม่ต้องเดินนะใช่ครับไม่ต้องเดินนี้
ครับเราขึ้นหรือไปได้นี่อยู่ในนี้อยู่ใน
เล็บช่วงนี้แล้วก็ยืนเฉยๆรอให้ลิฟต์
เลื่อนขึ้นไป
เรือนขึ้นไปอ้ะบนบ่นเอาวัดพระธาตุดอย
สุเทพให้หาใช้กับเราต้องจ่ายเงินไหมคะใช่
ครับต้องจ่ายเงินต้องจ่ายเงินเป็นค่าขึ้น
ลิฟต์ไปอ่ะต้องจ่ายเงินด้วยครับจ่ายเงิน
20 บาท
R  20 บาทเป็นค่าค่าลิฟต์นี้อ้าไม่ต้อง
เดินหน้าขึ้นลิฟต์ไปเกินๆๆต้องเดินไม่
เหนื่อยอ่ะอ่า
โอเคสำหรับคนที่เดินไม่ไหวนะครับโอเคอ่ะ
อ่ะเดี๋ยวเราขึ้นไปบนพระธาตุดอยสุเทพมี
อะไรบ้างต้องมีสิ่งที่สวยงามที่คุ้มค่า
กับการที่เราเดินขึ้นไปแน่นอนนี่ครับอ่า
นี้คือพระธาตุพระธาตุที่อยู่บนดอยสุเทพ
ครับหน้านี่เป็นพระธาตุสีทอง
ทองสวยงามเลยอ๋อ k6 สงสัยทุเรียนเสร็จ
เดินเหนื่อยเคยขึ้นบันไดเหนื่อยนะไอไอออก
มาก
ถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวเราพักพักผ่อนด้วยกันเดินดู
รอบๆเดินดูความสวยงามรอบๆวัดและโอเคอ่า
เดี๋ยวเพียงตี้พาไปดูอ้าวถ้าไปดูวิววิว
หลังวัดวิวหลังวัดก็สวยงามมากเหมือนกัน
ใช่ครับอ่าค่ะวันนี้ครับนะเป็นวิววิวที่
อยู่หลังวัดหลังวัดพระธาตุดอยสุเทพมีวิว
แบบนี้อ่ะเห็นนี่ครับเป็น
จังหวัดเชียงใหม่ใช่เป็นเมืองเชียงใหม่
อยู่ข้างล่างผลเลยอ่าทรายครับหือว้าวสวย
งามมากมีเมฆอยู่ไกลๆนี่ภูเขาภูเขาอยู่ไกล
ๆเลยอ่านี่ครับหน้าสวยไหมครับ
สวยมากสวยมากแค่นี้หายเหนื่อยและหาย
เหนื่อยอ่ะหายอ่าไปเที่ยวกันต่อได้นะครับ
เคเคแล้วก็อ้าเดี๋ยวอ่าเมื่อมาถึงวัดพระ
ธาตุดอยสุเทพและยังมีอีกที่นึงที่ขึ้นไป
อีกได้ขึ้นไปบนภูเขาอีกได้
ให้รีบไม่ค่ะพี่อ่ะดีแล้วอันนี้ขับรถไป
ได้ขับรถไอ้ได้อ๋อไม่ต้องเดินได้ครับอ้า
ขับรถไปที่นี่ครับนี่ไปที่ดอยปุย
ดอยปุยๆครับบนดอยก็จะมีนี่บนดอยก็จะมีชาว
เขาอยู่นะครับนี่มีชาวเขาชาวเขาแปลว่าคน
ที่อาศัยอยู่บนภูเขาหน้าเราเรียกว่าชาว
เขาใช่ครับชาวเขาเขาเขาจะมีบ้านใช่ไหมคะๆ
มีบ้านอยู่บนภูเขาอยู่บนภูเขาๆครับ
ชาวเขาครับเป็นชาวเขาอ่ะอาศัยอยู่บนภูเขา
ปลูกบ้านอยู่บนภูเขาด้วยว่าว้าวนี่จะเป็น
เช้าเขา
อยู่บนดอยปุยดอยปุยอ่ะเป็นชื่อเป็นชื่อภู
เขาหน้าพี่ปุ๋ยว้าว
ดอยปุยๆครับต้องอยู่ข้างบนใช่ไหมคะอยู่
ข้างบนใช่ครับบทข้างล่างถ้าอยู่ข้างล่าง
เป็นดอยไหมคะพี่ข้างล่างไม่เป็นดอยอย่า
ให้เป็นรอยอยู่ข้างบนสูงช่ายใจเขาดอยอ่า
ดอยอันนี้เป็นดอยปุ้ยอ่ะชื่อว่าดอยปุย
หน้าเก
ว้าววันนี้หนาวอ้าข้างบนก็จะหนาวหนาวกว่า
หนาวกว่าที่อยู่ข้างล่างอ่าซ้ายคลับ
ว้าวสนุกมากเลยวันนี้ไปเที่ยวกันหลายที่
เลยครับอ่าเหนื่อยกันหรือยังเดิน 1
เหินเดินขึ้นภูเขาคือหนูเขาเหนื่อยอ่ะแต่
ก็ได้เห็นวิวสวยๆมีความ
สูบ 5v ความสุขนข้ครับเออๆเดี๋ยวข้าวหน้า
เขาหน้าเพื่อที่จะพาไปเที่ยวที่อื่นอีก
ไหมครับเคลื่องอีกแล้วคะในเกมใหม่ที่อื่น
อีกในเชียงใหม่ใช่ครับมีที่เพราวาวแล้ว
เดี๋ยวเรามีโอกาสเราไปเที่ยวด้วยกันใหม่
น่าไปเที่ยวด้วยแล้วก็คิดเปลี่ยนรู้คำ
ศัพท์ใหม่ๆด้วยกันหน้าไปเรียนไปรู้จักที่
ต่างๆด้วยกันนะครับอ่ะโอเคสำหรับวันนี้นะ
ครับเดี๋ยวเปียตีกับน้องเรียมแล้วก็ต้อง
กับงานก่อนใช่ครับน้าาาขอบคุณใจกันใหม่ใน
ที่หน้าอ้าเดี๋ยวกลับมาเจอกันใหม่ครับวัน
นี้สวัสดีครับสวัสดีค่ะพี่ๆปีสวัสดีนัก
เรียนสวัสดีครับทุกคนบ๊ายบายแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่
อ่า
โอเคความดอยดอยปุยขึ้นดอยหล่อดอยเต่า